on july 4th the 16th annual symetra
classic rally got underway and for the
fourth time electric cars were part of
the field while the vintage classics one
over a new generation of fans this time
there was a slight change the classics
and plugins started off together rather
than separately as they had in the past
even some of the vintage cars have been
converted to the new technology one
vintage classic after another rolls off
the starting ramp but before they do
each driver gets a little good luck
charm from two local children and
vintage dress in sharp contrast to the
vintage cars are the electric vehicles
of twenty two V's such as the mercedes
sls AMG electric drive coupe a everyone
drives at their own pace some take their
time and enjoy the countryside the v's
are well advised to drive economically
the electric smart stands out from the
rest with its LED daytime running lights
and city street driving design
some cars are in a hurry like this audi
quattro and take advantage of a few
stretches of open road
the odd one out is the only privately
owned fuel cell powered Mercedes b-class
the owner Klaus egga gives his
impression it's just beautiful you get a
whole new feeling behind the wheel but
you're more conscious of energy
consumption and the environment when
driving you have to think about finding
the right filling station well in
advance because not many of them are
equipped for it yet there are currently
only a handful of hydrogen filling
stations in Germany some of the rally
drivers are still climbing the high
alpine sill ventra road while others are
already headed back down the same way
on this rally there's always time to
enjoy the scenery
before the day is over both the footage
garb and EV drivers have to pass a
special stage the idea is to drive a
certain distance in a predetermined time
as precisely as possible
the spectators are waiting at the finish
line with a bottle of sparkling wine as
a gift to each driver
later on the market square the
spectators have a chance to see the cars
close-up and what do the vintage car
buff say about the plugins
it's odd when they come along so quietly
and then here it is I think it's the
future of cars I think like in the next
20 years everything will be electric
board ullatec modern technology is good
to see but the classics aren't bad
either he has never driven an EV I would
like to try it sometime others wouldn't
hear of it this man says a real engine
has to have at least 12 cylinders
bourbon prio says it's time people
change the way of thinking about new
cars certain things just need to be
taken good care of and the last longer
it's been calculated the driving a car
for 20 years we use about the same
amount of energy resources as it takes
to manufacture and then scrap a little
so it makes sense to keep a car and
drive it just as long as possible
getting electric car to drive as long
and as far as possible is the aim of
current research and development on EVs
such as the hybrid XL one from
volkswagen the smart electric drive is
already on the market and germany it
starts in just over 13 thousand euros
if we're not honest eka mercede says
there are different applications for
different automotive technologies it's a
smart with the battery electric drive
has been in high-volume series
production since last year selling
direct to the end consumer that shows
that the car is practical for everyday
and can be produced in series of course
the fuel cell is the more modern
costlier newer technology and this car
proves these new technologies can
achieve a very long range so it has
qualities from both drive systems is
assisting mission last item
the symmetric classic rally and month of
phone also puts qualities from vintage
classics and state-of-the-art electric
cars on the road together
you